there she is
diaz you did it they found him guilty on
all charges
huh boyle's advice worked
so where's your happy place i'm in a
cabin
in the middle of nowhere inside it's
just me and that stupid slimy defense
attorney
and i'm beating the hell out of him i
break a dining room table over his head
then i rip off his arm and shove it
where the sun don't shine
then i reach down his throat and shake
his hand
yeah okay i'm gonna go ahead and
schedule you for a psyche valve
i owe you one boyle thank you dinner
tomorrow night for baldi's that's all
you can eat linguini
yes oh my boyfriend's coming too you're
what right now everything okay with diaz
yeah she fell asleep five minutes after
i locked her in and she hasn't moved in
the past
10 hours she talks in her sleep
i'm gonna rip your head off i'm gonna
rip your damn head off grandma
oh terribare what if she sleeps forever
oh look rosa you look great girl i gotta
get out of here bye
better not run because i will catch you
after i'm done crushing that perp you
are next
i already interrogated the perp for you
you what i got him to name his giggle
pig supplier
it's all good now go home and get better
i could have done it myself
no you couldn't have you literally have
been in a coma since yesterday
now i know you like to act like you
don't need any help but we all do
i asked five dudes to spot me when i'm
doing my squats terry paid me 20
to lock you up no i did not but i took
that cheddar and i made you this
special rosa's gonna make this called
her [ __ ] care package
now's the time when you say thank you
for all your help
thank you for all your help
wait is that a smile i see possibly
my immune system is too weak to fight
off my smile muscles
maybe put hitchcock's head on top like
an angel hmm
i don't like that no put it behind the
tree
thanks for helping me make this card
you're so good at this stuff i know i'm
good at everything
all right so here's all the pictures of
rosa that we have which one should we
use
ugh she never smiles is her mouth broken
well what about if we flip
those lips oh god that's horrifying
we have to get a picture of rosa smiling
hold card has to be perfect
guys i got this i can make rosa smile
just keep your cameras ready
making coffee can you make another cup
for seeing your tickle in this new heavy
amigos
what the hell no
i i think you sprint see your tickle
next time i break it off
oh you know everyone should just go home
and enjoy their christmas
you don't need to stick around here for
me shut up no one's going anywhere
what you did was amazing yeah boyle that
was some superman stuff
yeah you did the nine nine proud no ifs
ands or butts
sorry it's just right there literally
it's just right in front of me his butt
is right in my face
i have to tell you guys something even
though i got shot in the butt
sorry i'd rather be here spending
christmas with all of you
than on some stupid singles cruz and i
mean that for the bottom of my
butt again sorry wow shut up jake
will's a hero and so is his butt
i got it she smiled christmas card
complete
he got shot in the butt
hey so i checked again doug judy still
hasn't surfaced
yeah he has he just sent me this
what's up peralta greetings from
paradise
actually i'm a little disappointed in
the hotel how do you mess up the
omelette
it's just a flat egg he pretty much just
talks about the omelet for the next 10
minutes
but about my escape this is my associate
kyle
he drove the garbage truck you may also
remember him as the room service waiter
i had you tip
so generously son of a [ __ ]
yeah and when he ordered the lobster it
was code for kyle to follow him
anyway tell diaz she loves me merry
christmas
okay first things first i swear to you
we are going to catch doug judy
yeah i know we did it once we can do it
again no
we will catch him more importantly thank
you
i know how hard that was to make that
choice and let him get away now
it was an easy call i know how much this
task force means to you you mean so much
it's been so stressful and went so well
seriously look at me i cannot stop
smiling
how do people do this with their faces
[Music]
hey there beautiful marcus what are you
doing here
well i know you lost your phone charger
so i got you a new one yeah i want to
make sure your phone's all juiced up for
some
sweet long distance texting thanks what
do i owe you
it's a gift all you got to say is thank
you i said thank you that was the first
thing i said
sorry you're nice i'll text you
can't wait inappropriate work kids too
fast can't stop me
rosa d knocking down with her boo on the
street
i love it cebu again i will shoot you in
the stomach
fine love a boy it is what did i just
say charlie what did i just
say not to say it marcus detective diaz
what a surprise i didn't expect you for
another
nine and a half minutes see told you it
was rude to be early well let's cancel
the entire evening and try again next
year
she is hilarious i thought you might
need some help setting up
oh i'll put these in some water thank
you marcus you can help with the buffer
i sub shallots for onions in the
mirepoix no are you kidding
i have no idea
okay before we go in remember you have
to pretend to be surprised
how's this oh my god it's so much worse
than i imagined
the energy was great but the message was
flawed all right let's get this over
with
surprise what's going on
i rented this entire bar so you and i
could celebrate with
no people anywhere near us probably
should have hired a bartender though i
have no idea how to make drinks
this is incredible it's all charles's
idea
i told you i knew you wrote row thank
you
but never call me roro again oh but i
will i've earned this
happy b day roro
okay so i'm going to face my fear of
confined spaces
when i'm ready you will shut the trunk
and leave me here for 30 minutes i left
a juice box and a diaper in there for
you so
you're gonna be fine or we could all
give in to our fears and keep our blood
in our bodies like normal people
no rosa we are doing something important
here we are women
standing up and supporting each other
and becoming
new fear listening to amy inspire us be
back in a half hour ames
wait come back come back i can't do this
no you're the best
you did it how'd it go well
the first 10 minutes were really
terrible the diaper did not fit
it was for a baby but then i relaxed
and i found my inner strength i think
the lesson here is that as women
we no you close that truck again and i
will kill you you hear me i will kill
you
isabel cortez welcome to your new home
this is going to be fun
really what are your weekends like diaz
all right
it's time detective don't forget you're
seven months pregnant your cervix is
ripening as we speak
mention my cervix again and i will rip
your throat out i don't understand you
don't like it when he talks about your
cervix ripening
okay have fun
oh my god rosa i accidentally opened
your mail but look what it says
dear miss diaz you just won rosa
guess what i accidentally opened your
mail and here's what it says dear miss
diaz you just won
no i'm reading the letter and you're
taking the picture
i'm trying to get me to smile for your
dumb picture but you messed up
god she smiled she's smiling and no one
has a camera
it amy got a picture you frowning that's
what you wanted right
here she comes big smiles
hey rosa hey how's my bike great
it actually was a lot of fun to ride
once i got the hang of it
[Music]
and you were able to finish everything
on my list wasn't too much was it
no not at all if anything you didn't ask
enough of us great cause i thought of a
few more things
oh are you able to send that email to
adrian oh yes he wrote back right away
it wasn't as graphic as i feared he
wrote the number eight
equal sign equal sign equal sign equal
sign
equal sign equal sign equal sign capital
d oh
i see what this is
you